The Borghese Gallery is one of the most celebrated museums in the entire world,...
...filled with art from some of the most famous artists in history.
It houses the world's largest collection of Caravaggio,...
...a room full of masterpieces by Raphael, and early sculptures by Bernini.
This gallery has a limit of 300 visitors every two hours...
...so you can really get up close and personal with the art.
Nothing is roped off.
It's like you're a guest of the Borgheses.
This is absolutely breathtaking.
You don't need to be an art historian to appreciate this place.
It is so vibrant, so full of color,...
...so full of life and you will leave feeling blown away.
The Borghese Garden, you can come here, chill out,...
..have something to eat, a picnic, take in the sunshine, the nature,...
...or just enjoy the serenity.
Wow, that was a once in a lifetime experience.
I've never seen such beautiful art in my life.